shroud is one of the biggest streamers
out there and with good reason he's
still got that crispy aim from his csgo
glory base what a flick coming in trout
getting one of the headshots he's
tapping away shroud can he do it again
he's up to 11 kills and looking for
number 12 are you kidding me
but with all the success he's seen since
that time it's easy to forget and
important to remember that shroud built
his stream as an alternative to a life
of competition you're not going to see
me go pro in a game ever again if you
truly want to play at the top
like the top top
you
cannot
stream
your practice
you can't along the way he's done so
many things that would likely have been
impossible had he remained a pro player
like spreading the love i gave a shout
out to a drummer and then he was just
playing like some of my favorite bands
and stuff on the drums and everything
then another one i hosted a singer
and she made like an album now so she's
doing really really well even when
twitch thinks that it's too much love
for one stream he loves keeping his desk
clean
oh look at that crease oh
and he's got some
interesting associates
what's up everybody what are you what
are you what do you what do you what are
you what is it so today we are looking
at the weird facts about shroud from the
more mundane
to the truly strange
and if you think we're going to avoid
certain subjects
you couldn't be more wrong
[Music]
all right guys josh is out this week
which means that yours truly will be
leading you through this deep dive but
before we submerge ourselves in all
things shroud i'm gonna ask that you
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications because that
sweet sweet ad revenue is
hopefully gonna let us buy an air
freshener for this heap of junk
what does josh eat down here
anyway let's get down to business and
start exploring below the surface of the
shroud iceberg
coolest dad now if you've watched enough
videos in our story of series it feels
like every single esports pro had an
older brother that introduced them to
gaming but for shroud it was his dad
tomasz who loved games before that was a
cool thing that only the coolest people
did i always had like new tech i had
like some crazy mp3 player that played
video it was just weird my dad was just
huge on building computers so every like
year he'd have a new computer i know i
love games i love games i love computers
i i build every single computer we own
and
and i was a big time player uh not
professionally or anything
just for fun
and i love games and i stay late so many
nights but when papa shroud let tiny
little baby shroud try cs
that's when things really took off and
then i introduced him to counter-strike
because i like that game and he picked
up so quickly that after a couple of
months there was pointless for me to
play with him
eclipsed by shroud
when you think of eclipse you probably
think of this kind of eclipse
you probably don't associate it with
shroud but his previous alias was m
eclipse he ended up changing it to
shroud a synonym because eclipse was a
way more popular name if you look at the
back catalog of shroud's videos you can
find plenty of references to his old
handle and he's still got an old channel
on youtube under that name of course now
that he's one of the biggest streamers
on twitch shroud is also often a very
difficult name to secure so he sometimes
uses his last name gersheshik but
backwards the name shroud is now an
iconic part of the twitch landscape and
shroudy rowdy sure as hell sounds a lot
better than
eclipsey
tipsy what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things i have ever heard
i tried okay
alright now that the obvious is in the
rear view mirror let's move on to the
bands beans and bones wait why does this
thing have a rear view mirror anyway
pubg prison
playerunknown's battlegrounds was an
important game for shroud he was an
early adopter and quickly became known
as one of the best players out there
and uh that's how it's done it's clear
that shroud and pubg both helped each
other grow but in spite of that he's
actually been banned from the game on
two separate occasions the first was for
teaming with a hacker and sure
it was a pretty funny moment
[Music]
wait that that's not the right footage
[Laughter]
are you sure you want to go here there's
no players here
i'm getting bad
anyways the first time was way cooler
than the second time when people were
stream sniping him on the test server
and following him around shroud made an
innocuous comment to follow him which
apparently earned him a ban
from just the test server
java fiend
shroud loves coffee
whether he's slamming it at his desk
or
grabbing one with dead mouse i've been
playing since like kind of 1.6 but then
you know i i did cz for a hot minute and
then and then go came out and i was a
little bit better with that he's just an
absolute fiend for that burnt bean juice
come on and
now we'll get back here no
dog is a little [__] coffee has
another role in shroud stream though
madrina's coffee was the first ever
broadcast sponsorship and that means
they kind of bought a piece of shroud
history less than a year later shroud
was even promoting the canned coffee
brands launch outside of a walmart just
got out of walmart and i bought like 12
cans of madrinas even though i get that
[__] for free just want to let you guys
know flex
i'm outtie
i just want to let you guys know i came
back for the camp okay i'm going to
recycle it i'm an adult
scooter accident
now you may not know this but back in
march of 2019 trout actually hurt
himself pretty badly after falling off
of his scooter according to information
from his friend justin shroud flipped
over the front of the scooter after
braking hard and landed on his left
elbow injuring much of his arm shroud
went into surgery the same day while
justin kept people updated my first
surgery was
not like a big surgery was very very
small it was just like
a cleaning like debris cleaning and [__]
make sure it's not infected and then i
need to wait until uh my evaluation
which is
start next week after a second surgery
shroud sported a cast for some time but
at least in terms of gaming
he's back to 100 percent
what's bottom through
nice well done
all right things are starting to heat up
down here so let's take a look at the
things that make shroud sweat of it
wow addiction
shroud is an old-school wow fan and like
any friends you may have who play wow
it's pretty much guaranteed that he'll
be there when the new expansion drops he
also returns to the game's halcyon days
by playing wow classic where he mained a
shaman and cleared all of the game's
raid content including naxxramas
[Music]
you can do it you can do it
but shroud likes wow a lot enough that
he was willing to drop a lot of money to
be able to make a raid time that would
have otherwise been impossible the rowdy
one explained that he actually chartered
a private flight to make it back home in
time for a raid and that the trip cost
him 10 times what a normal airline
ticket would have how much did it cost
six
600 an hour so it was two hours
it was around that price it was [__] it
was something like that six six
something an hour
oh my god
on top of that most of shroud's regular
viewers are there to see some crispy aim
not stranglethorn veil pvp so simply
streaming wow classic instead of
something else brought its own costs in
terms of viewership subs and donations
adderall use
the performance enhancing substance
debate has been hanging over the esports
community for a long time and we're not
talking about steroids because while
there are some pretty jacked people in
counter-strike it's not necessarily an
in-game advantage the substance in
question is the one that affects your
mental abilities
adderall it's a commonly prescribed
treatment for adhd but it developed a
reputation as a performance enhancer in
video games
adderall use became a hot topic in 2015
after one of shroud's former teammates
semphis admitted in an interview with
launders that he and the rest of the
team had been using adderall at esl one
katowice 2015. i don't even care we're
all on adderall like well i don't even
give like
it was pretty obvious like if you listen
to the calms like
uh people can hate it or whatever and
everyone does
all the esga land right yeah the comms
do certainly seem a bit
animated so what are we going to do
we're just going to go just
i'm going to go just through this i
don't want to just die because we're
confused no no no flash for me
i have no flash flash i got it i got
control
come through this movie control i'm
going to
but i think the top comment on this
video nails it
shroud still sounds pretty low-key
during this whole sequence
could abuse halls this round
coming up
there's two in banana yeah
it's kind of late no no save it save it
save it flash clear calls you want me to
see them save it tell me what yeah
probably
10 seconds 10 seconds
could be water water there's water it's
water restricted under water yeah but
i'm waiting for uh shroud hasn't
confirmed whether he was using adderall
during the event though he has
separately admitted that he used it
while reviewing the team's demos i only
took it one time and it was a very very
very small amount didn't really do much
for me like i could focus a little bit
better on this that i was i was studying
demos at the time
and it helped me keep my attention on
the demo and nothing else i didn't like
side
track on anything
saga
the rise of streaming changed so much in
terms of how we entertain ourselves
online
but it also gave way to a new phenomenon
the stream sniper they're often just
trying to piss the streamer off
but the mysterious figure known as wadu
heck met shroud in pubg and he wasn't
trying to provoke simple rage
instead
he was just
weird as hell
why the heck just like that that's it
i do heck okay
he seemingly could only say the words
wadu heck
like he was a
fallout npc or something
gary
oh and he definitely died like an npc
too whether he was getting bonked by a
frying pan
or trying to bring azathoth into the
material plane
what
i love it i love it they weren't
fighting anyone they were just trolling
oh my
god
wadu heck's appearance in shroud stream
was always a highlight is that really
you
i do
that's the sound board no
why the heck
oh no it is you
no no come back come back i'm sorry
i didn't know what the heck
average skin enthusiast if you've ever
watched shroud play a game where skins
are a thing
you know that he's pretty into them
cloud9 2014 dreamhack hey i was at this
event
trucker only 80 dollars this is
horseshit this is gambling
this is illegal
and he famously played a 2v2 aim map
match in cs with simple on his team
against summit 1g and mo where he had to
win 10 games and his opponents only had
to win one they uh
didn't all right
i'm gonna lose the dragon lore they're
not gonna be able to maintain this
they're not for 10 perhaps
maybe they are
obviously
i can't do it i can't do it i someone
they have to play you one more time with
somebody oh my god dude
but in counter strike he opens a lot of
cases too sometimes at the weirdest
possible times feeling
sorry i was opening a case hold on hold
on good luck open good luck
we're good we're good we're better are
you actually diffusing instead of
opening what are you doing you're right
hold on
i could open one
we're fine we're fine what do you mean i
just had to open one real quick
skins equals wins
blessed by our in jesus
we talked about shroud's love of opening
cases but there was one event that made
everyone wonder whether he was truly
gaben's apostle in march of 2019 shroud
was running some pugs and opening up
some new prisma cases and
he was feeling pretty good about his
chances
i'm gonna get lucky just so you wait
unless you wait and see how many of two
knives
and one crate but it wasn't just bravado
because a couple of cases later
he was the one flexing
oh
okay
who got a knife huh i did but while one
phase four doppler was good
two
is obviously better
again
are you [__] kidding me the same
thing two of them
is this real
csgo skin fiend anomaly also unboxed the
exact same knife during his own
simultaneous stream and jokingly tried
to pass it off as shrouds using a name
tag
open it by shroud
was it opened by shroud
i'll name mine open by shroud
and look i'm not exactly sure how it
went for anomaly but
it's only fair that a little bit of
shroud's luck gets shared with others
finally we've reached the bottom of this
colossal iceberg but i have a feeling
there's something else that's pretty
huge down here could shroud have one
major
we talked in the intro about how shroud
was and continues to be regarded as one
of north american counter-strike's
greatest mechanical prodigies his stint
with cloud9 ended in august of 2017
but just over five months later cloud9
won a cs major north america's first
guardian waste
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work
[Applause]
major champions
that august shroud retired and his boy
nothing got benched the org replaced
them with rush and tariq who were
acquired from optic so we have to ask if
shroud had stayed on and c9 had only
added say tariq
would they still have won the major it's
possible although the c9 that played the
first half of 2017 wasn't exactly
putting up incredible stats so it's
pretty hard to use numbers as a point of
comparison here even though this is just
an imaginary scenario we might have been
closer to this reality than we think
both nothing and shroud were on the
bench and could have been used in the
event that one of the main roster
couldn't play now that didn't happen but
it could have a major win would
obviously have been amazing for shroud
but since he basically conquered twitch
i think we can call it even
he has a fat what
okay so if you've spent any amount of
time in his stream it's not difficult to
remember
shroud's
member it's not like you're a massive
dude but you got like good sized feet
which means you have a fat [__] it
became a popular meme in his community
after some donations referenced it
is that you got a fat [__]
look at the clock tick tock tick tock
running out of time and i need your fat
[__] it's the biggest on the block i
crave the sudden shock of my ass getting
rocked
what's up
and some pointed to a very over the top
sexual harassment training video
as a potential source for those messages
word around the offices you've got a fat
[__]
yes i do
i've got a fat [__] too it's unlikely
that we'll ever know for sure but when
shroudy played cyberpunk
well
i'll let you see for yourself
pubic hairstyle penis size
wait
what
perfect perfect we're looking damn good
so there we have it the shroud iceberg i
feel like there's a lot of things we
didn't get into and more stuff we could
have explored like the justin
relationship or the luggage resale saga
let us know in the comments if there's
anything more you wanted us to look into
and
see you next time
i switched my cs go sensitivity to
shroud cs go sensitivity but i haven't
run on the 2.4 man and the shroud sends
is the godsense dude whatever this man
plays at that is the god sense i'm
convinced like
whatever it is and if he changes his
sense i'll change mine from this point
forward i don't even care but i'll go in
his stream commands and i'll be like at
like exclamation point sends i'm like
whatever it is i'm gonna adopt that [__]
man it's
this man's a god he knows